freunde herzlich willkommen zu einer
neuen folge ein tag persönlicher koch
endlich mal wieder mit einem besonderen
gast in liebenscheid herzlich willkommen
auf meinem feld heute wird es
orientalisch schnitt aus dir eigentlich
nur orientalische speisen wenn auch
wichtig und das liegt auch bertrand ich
schaue mir natürlich auch das format
immer ein
persönlicher kochen und ich habe daraus
gehört und versuchst du mal dahin gästen
so authentisch wie möglich verschiedene
kulturen nahe zu bringen auf jeden fall
unter verstehen wieso ist meine kultur
heute mitgebracht und 3 zum frühstück
gibt es cool was es seht ihr jetzt du
kannst dich ganz entspannt zurücklehnen
und ich bereite das ich
habe
das ist vielleicht die denen danke dir
dein eigenes messer tagesbester also ist
nicht
okay dann brauchen wir
also heute
basiert auf diesen wohnen hier das sind
sauberen bzw farben und kichererbsen und
ich muss wirklich sagen ich habe das
noch nie gegessen ich habe das noch nie
gekocht und ich bin sehr gespannt wie es
schmecken wird übrigens heute zum ersten
mal nicht eric hinter der kamera tristan
du kannst nicht einmal ein mal hallo
sagen hallo tristan filme normalerweise
für schafe und hasen freund bei mir
auszuhelfen dann geben wir einfach die
bodentiere in unserer partei und stellt
erst mal an und kochen auf unser gericht
unser tool besteht aus zwei komponenten
einmal den bohnen beziehungsweise
kichererbsen und dann aus einer joghurt
sesam zitronen passte die sehr sehr
lecker sein soll hier schneiden als
aller erstes mal die zitrone in die
hälfte mit meisterschaft und er ist
wirklich selbst aber sehr gut dann
brauchen wir eine knoblauchzehe hier ist
schon aufgekauft das heißt mit anderen
worten wir können jetzt eigentlich schon
runterstellen bisschen warm halten dann
starten wir uns eine schüssel geben
diese schiffe einen großzügigen es
löffel joghurt dann so ein hype
esslöffel karin wichtig hält nicht
dunkel also dass das flüssige eine halbe
zitrone die können wir in die hand
pressen damit wenn gerne raus kommen sie
einfach darin liegen bleiben die
wahnsinnig schnell auf dieses zu stecken
also wirklich die zeit oder vermischt er
das ganze ja einmal
dann eine knoblauchzehe die pressen wir
dazu wollte das hat wirklich das wird
knoblauch ich soviel kann ich sagen auch
das wird einfach
so und jetzt nehmen wir von unseren
wohnen hier etwas von der flüssigkeit ab
und geben das ebenfalls zu unserer
mischung dazu kommt dann noch mehr das
aroma von den boden rein manche leute
mögen das auch nicht so sehr dann macht
man es einfach mit wasser aber in jedem
fall wenn man den authentischen
geschmack haben wir jetzt das ganz genau
der richtige weg ist im pfeffer etwas
dran
ich verstehe schon ich verstehe warum
man zwar dazu kommt jetzt noch ein
halber teelöffel kreuzkümmel und sag
euch der ist wichtig dann braucht ihr
noch eine tomate aber meinte er mag es
gerne extrabreit darauf achten
für unser tool ist fast alles fertig ich
mache jetzt die pfanne heiß und wir
machen das spiel aber nicht irgendwie
sondern besonders weil wir arbeiten mit
der hitze beim spiegel ein und deshalb
hat ja auch erst muss er in die pfanne
und kein olivenöl und auch durch
ordentliche versus soll vielleicht
schwimmen können waren es auf jeden fall
schön hitze haben wenn wir unsere
eigenen eingeben jetzt schlagen wir
unser eigen hinein wir gehen jetzt die
mit dem toben kann sei ihr seht schon
jetzt quasi von oben einmal geschlossen
und verläuft nicht mehr und wenn jetzt
einmal drunter gucken ihr seht schon
wirklich knusprig takt ging es runter
und es werden wir noch unser tool an und
dann wird gegessen
so schauen lieber ich hoffe es wird für
mich sehr getroffen das wichtigste zum
schluss schön mit dem ordentlich
olivenöl nochmal drüber das gibt noch
mal eine schöne farbe rein das sieht auf
jeden fall ich traue auch geschmacklich
du musst jetzt man sagen ob es
geschmeckt hat schon natürlich ist noch
nie noch nie dabei nicht kommentarlos
werden ausnahmen ich zeig dir über das
ist ja alles im forum des humor ich
sowieso ein gutes stück näher egal ob
kreis oder her ich mache das jetzt ein
bisschen sozusagen dann nimmt man hier
so ein bisschen was dran sein ritchie
ist ja schon etwas zu machen ist
mitarbeiter mit eine sache für ein
bisschen seite besetzen ich meine ein
bisschen mehr hat aber so an sich
wunderbar wenn ich bei einer sein hätte
ich selbst nicht und da dabei wussten
nicht wie michael dran sein muss auch
hier mit brot
aber kann man nicht noch buchen so
verhalten dass ich mal die rallye führte
2009 wirklich leute ein unfassbarkeit
frühstück und für viele viele da draußen
wahrscheinlich eine sache die sie wie
ich noch nie probiert haben deshalb auf
jeden fall probiert danke dass du es mir
gezeigt hast komme ich hab das format so
lange nicht gemacht normalerweise ist es
so man probiert eine pause und dann
kommt die bewertung der wird aber
durchgehend gelagert kommen wir zur
bewertung liegt dir neu zu errichten
oder willst hast du wirklich wunderbar
heraus mit in tallinn note hast du mich
die kette ja ich liebe dich über alles
was ein guter start in den tag weiter
geht's mit dem mittagessen wo auch
wieder alles ein bisschen anders ist
entscheidung hilft mir dabei warum
erfahrt ihr jetzt da sind wir also zu
mittag essen und wie gesagt es wird
besonders du hast ein rezept mitgebracht
dass ich für dich kommen
genau und das ist irre ich mich
operieren lassen und natürlich auch
durch meine heimat könnten übernommen
dies mag gerne schließen bei der ich
liebe also wirklich liebe schafft dabei
angesprochen in genres video das kommt
heute um 8 uhr auf schloss kanal wir
waren in einem meiner lieblingswörter
ausweis vorgezeigt was sehr sehr wenig
beschreiben wir was muss ich machen sagt
sagte ich werde sie sagen und ich glaub
an dich denke du bist ja so hinbekommen
ok ich fange an in dem ich erst mal mit
knapp 13 knoblauch mit dem ordentlich
koriander und ihr habt jetzt einfach
alle drei zutaten fein
so alles fertig geschnitten das heißt
jetzt ordentlich olivenöl in unsere
große fahne rein also sowie armut gesagt
hat das soll ruhig den ganzen boden
bedecken schon fast ein bisschen darin
stimmt auf jeden fall in öl heutiges
gericht bevor wir das ganze anbraten
haben jetzt hier eine große schüssel mit
lauwarmen wasser gefüllt und darin
weichen jetzt die meisten blätter ein
also einmal kurz unter wasser drücken
dass sie alle vernetzt sind dann nehmen
wir uns den ganzen spaß hier und geben
ihn rüber in die pfanne es beginnt
direkt zu duften hier ist schön
eingeweicht alles kommen wir zu unserer
marke wir nehmen sie uns und bringen das
ganze wasser aus und man merke ich hatte
gar beide hände voll
ja wirklich die seife das hier waren
dort zwei volle hände also wir schreiben
hier nochmal ein bisschen olivenöl nach
unten rein geben bis die tomate dazu
kommen gehe ich noch ein bisschen öl
dran die tomate hacken wir jetzt grob
geben sie dann auch dass du zu unserer
meile zu unserer kräutermischung und die
liefert eben nochmal feuchtigkeit ab
die blätter die durch sehr sehr
aufnahmen freudig sind und ich glaube
das ist auch so ein bisschen der trick
von dem ganzen rezept das dann in diesen
ländern einfach diese saftigkeit der
geschmack das aroma von allen zutaten
einfach aufgesogen wird also darüber mit
den tomaten vier stück waren das jetzt
an der zeit jetzt so viel feuchtigkeit
da dass der knoblauch garantiert brennen
kann ist halt ein bisschen hochgeht
temperaturen sowie kommen da ich die
nudeln das lassen wir noch ein bisschen
weiter kommen dann kommen die garnele
hat sehen wir uns nochmal und das auch
schon fertig
also schade wir sind deine spaghetti
deine kreationen die netto sie
eigentlich gegen großen namen dafür
müsst ihr den namen überlebensgroß minar
in berlin oder vielleicht macht das auch
deine community opa ihr können wir die
konzert haben die sowieso in diese
partie heißen und du kannst dir
überlegen die schmecken die gleiche
paket probieren diesmal haben wir es
klassisch zu probierst verrät nicht
allzu viel machen den cut
[Musik]
ich glaube dass reiche leute wir sehen
uns gleich wieder wenn auch gegessen ist
also klar oh was hast du dann bitte für
ein gericht ist und ich hab vergessen
diese man blätter sind so folgte somit
geschmack und haben auch beim kaum fast
so eine textur wie so eine
fleischbeilage oder so wahnsinn wirklich
respekt dafür dass du dir selbst das
überlegt hast super lecker aber war es
auch für dich super lecker ist jetzt
dass mehrere hat super gepasst eine
sache britischen bemängelt erstellt dkk
während hettich frische ok richtig
schöne die griechen ihre also aber waren
geschlossen keine falten
projektentwicklung und ich möchte dir
auch immer trüben ich weiß was mit
anderen wohnung stalker ist ja nichts
mit küche sage ich mal zu den frauen
ließ das gastmahl gemacht und
dann gespannt ob ich das halten kann ob
ich vielleicht asset gesehen hier über
komme ja beim abendessen werde ich erst
einmal alles geben wir sehen uns da und
dann kommen wir auch zum abendessen ich
bin auch fast ein bisschen gesättigt
kann die halten wirklich gut fahren es
ist nämlich nicht versuche das noch von
einem tool vorerst keine aussage auf
jeden fall habe wir machen jetzt drei
löffel salat und köpfte hast du dir auch
gewünscht ich würde sagen gelegen was
machst du dir gemütlich ist ich gebe
hier alles ich fange an dem ich hier die
gurke schneide ich lasse die schale dran
trat frisch gewaschen in schale sind die
vitamine bei so einer gurke wir werden
gar nicht so wahnsinnig viel brauche ich
nehme aber die schönsten arbeiten ist so
ein mittelstück hier raus dann halt die
noch eine richtig schöne kleine stücke
danken wir jetzt unsere cherrytomaten
die auch schön klein das heißt ich achte
bedienen sowie schnappen uns das jetzt
alles geben es zum treffen um zum
aufbewahren in eine schüssel geben wir
das schon mal ein bisschen zitrone leben
will das hat auf jeden fall auch eine
hauptrolle heute das wird ihnen ist da
kommen noch zwei weitere sachen dazu und
zwar ein bisschen petersilie und ein
bisschen zwiebel vierte zwiebel ist auf
jeden fall schon ordentlich für den
bereich schaffen wir unsere reise unsere
zwiebel und los geht's
und jetzt mal ein da kommt quasi fast
schon in gelee eigentlich schon fast so
fein gerieben ist auch so viele
wasserratten das aromatisiert vielleicht
das ganze vor das fängt schon an leute
fährt langsam sehr gestört gerade nehmen
so ungefähr 300 gramm hackfleisch
mehrfach dazu bemerkt die zutaten
wiederholen sich heute aber
funktionieren auch einfach gut zusammen
und wir sind ja auch generell unterwegs
sind der arabischen küche und bei
doppeln sich erst mal ein paar zutaten
wenn diese zielt natürlich irgendwann
arabisch ist dann nehmen wir hier noch
so etwa ein teelöffel von unserem
kreuzkümmel und unsere restliche
petersilie also wirklich jede menge
packen hierbei geben wir wirklich ganz
fein dann kommt da schon ein bisschen
pfeffer salz und dann können wir das
ganze auch schon durchhängen machst du
da noch ein bisschen ziehen das auf der
anteil vom fleisch an dieser masse für
die kräfte ist gar nicht mal so hoch
also so sieht unsere masse aussehen sie
fertig ist und so lassen wir jetzt noch
ein bisschen um die dritte sache fehlt
noch der humus und darum kümmern wir uns
jetzt ich habe hier vorne 250 gramm
kichererbsen einfach aus der dose aus
dem glas man kann ja auch über nacht
einweichen jeder der welt gebe ich jetzt
einmal hier in meinem messbecher hinein
dazu kommt so ein halber teelöffel
kreuzkümmel merkt alles wiederholt sich
das gibt einfach diesen klassischen
orientalischen
was auch nicht fehlen darf unser tallinn
auch nicht so viel wie man jetzt gar
keine große portion zwei teelöffel dann
natürlich auch in der zitrone eine ganze
zitrone gebe ich rein und wieder eine
prise salz pfeffer 1 heiko für joghurt
und wieder jede menge kohle
dazu kommt jetzt noch eine knoblauchzehe
und jetzt müssen wir das ganze nur noch
mixen
[Musik]
wenn es noch einiges abgeschmeckt also
ihr merkt dass es ein bisschen mehr
geworden weil ich habe gehört dass sein
muss angeht habe ich mal erst mal so
eine schöne schlüssel damit folgt wurden
die olivenöl
und in meinem fall jetzt geräumt hatte
paprika um das grill aroma ein bisschen
aufzugreifen
daraus folgen jetzt unsere kräfte würde
sagen einfach nach gefühl dass hier so
eine schöne größe hätte ich gesagt für
die selfmade optik alle unterschiedlich
groß was sind kay kraus wenn man kräfte
beraubt haben kann so ist schon dunkel
draußen und wir legen jetzt unsere
kräfte auf erstmal damit die nicht
ankleben bisschen fett drauf kann ein
bisschen brennen aber weiter schlimm
nach und nach
[Musik]
ich glaube wir sind auf einem guten weg
wir sehen uns einfach gleich wenn alles
angerichtet
[Musik]
hier ist das abendessen das sagt ja
manchmal ist sie wunderbar aus nur meine
richtung ich kenne meine kleine vor
allem eine arabische community wenn die
eu muss in der schüssel sehen machen wir
ja die schüssel eignet sich nicht
perfekt zum anrichten musste hast du
super dekoriert superjumbos am besten
flach hatte oder leicht berührt wird und
nicht nur ich muss ja das hat nicht so
heißen es wird vom geschmack ja ich sag
mal sagen muss dann anrichten mit humus
punkt der welt wo zu hören der giftige
rauch sehe hier die paare kommen hier
schön die schiene und petersilie
rauskommt sieht wirklich sehr frech so
richtig auf pavel angelehnt wie es
einfach probieren ja ich mache es mir
hier und da gar nicht überlesen streit
breche ihr so ein stück fleisch mit gut
ab nun gehe ich nur mit den humus hier
so im plan erst in rom moskau
ich habe ja schon einige manipuliert
mich nicht bittet
die seelische also ich muss wirklich
sagen ich feiere diese küche alles hast
du mir gezeigt dass heute wirklich sehr
wohl aber auch gefeiert wie ich das
zubereitet kabel sehen wir jetzt gleich
was er vermisse auf fertig mit lücke für
diese unsere gastfreundschaft sehr gerne
also was es war auch schön ich als gast
haben und danke dass du mir diese
wirklich sehr sehr interessant und
leckere küche näher das volk wirklich
weiß was das gericht unter problemen
immer schön dass du das versuchten er
zudem regt wunder eigentlich gute wahl
getroffen mit dem höchsten nicht absolut
gleich drei sachen jetzt gehabt bewerben
kannst du auch schlecht finden kannst
was sagst du warum muss ich bin dabei
recht hast du gut hinbekommen der
leichte co minute bitte du dann auch gut
reinkommen dafür hat mir ein bisschen
gefehlt von da wird es keine punkte
geben sondern achteinhalb ok anrichten
das projekt es wird wirklich nur uns
geschmack und das richtig gut getroffen
bisher mehr kommen etwa von eur 9 punkte
erreicht
besser so als albern richtig ist gut
fürs erste mal und fürs erste kräfte
kräfte du könntest du ja wohl arbeiten
schön sagt das nicht wer könnte ich gut
das hat auf jeden fall 9,2 was gibst du
jetzt im gesamten gesamten eine
gesamtnote für alles 9 19 23 fache 9
oder
ich danke dir danke dass ihr da wart
danke an dich auch tristan lassen
gefehlt habe es war wirklich ein cooler
tag wie gesagt unbedingt chance wieder
anschauen